can you
just because it sounded really cool uh
talk a little bit about stochastic
coalescence
and uh you have a paper on showing that
some you could describe what it is but i
guess it's a super linear super
logarithmic time and you
came up with some kind of trick to make
it faster just can you just talk about
it a little bit yeah so this was
something which came up
um when i was at microsoft research for
a summer and
that i'm putting that context because
that shows that it has some
practical motivation at some point
actually i think it still it doesn't
need to yeah it doesn't need to it could
be beautiful and it's all right
yeah so the easiest way to describe this
is suppose you got like a big crowd of
people
and everybody knows how many hours of
sleep they got last night
and you want to know how many total
hours of sleep were gotten by this big
big crowd of people at the beginning you
might say that sounds like a linear time
algorithm
of saying hey you how many hours you got
how many you got how many you got add
add yes but there's a way to do this
if you remember that there are people
and they presumably know how to add
you could make a distributed algorithm
to make this happen
for example while we're thinking of
these trees imagine you had 1024 people
if you could just say hey person number
one and person number two
you will add your hours of sleep person
number two will go away and person
number one is going to remember the sum
person three and four add up and person
three takes charge of remembering it
person four goes away now this like
person one knows the sum of these two
person three knows some of those two
they talk
you see what i mean it's like you're
going up this tree
same tree that we've talked about
earlier built up a tree from the bottom
up
yeah build the retreat from the bottom
up and the beautiful thing is
since everyone's doing stuff in parallel
the amount of time it takes
to get the total sum is actually just
the number of layers in the tree
which is 10. so now that's logarithmic
time to add up the number of hours
that people slept today sounds fantastic
yes
there's only one problem how do you
decide who's person number one and
person number two
yes so if for example you just went out
into the downtown and said hey get these
thousand people
go well if you're going to go and say
and by the way you're one and you're two
and you're three that's linear time
yes that's cheating so now the question
is how to do this in a distributed way
and there were some people who proposed
a very elegant algorithm
and they wanted to analyze it that's so
i came in onto the analyze side
but the elegant algorithm was like this
it was like well
we don't actually know what this big nut
big tree is there isn't any big tree
so what's going to happen is first
everyone is going to
decide right now oh what one important
thing
everyone is going to at the very
beginning of the whole
game uh they will have delegated
responsibility to themselves
as the one who knows the sum so far
so so the point is there's there's going
to be people are all going to have like
a pointer which says
uh you are the one who knows my you
you've taken care of my ticket my number
yeah okay they select the representative
for this
particular piece of knowledge right yep
and at the very beginning you're your
own representative
the thing has to start simple right so
at the beginning you're pointing to
yourself you got it
yep and and how the way this works is
that at every time step someone blares a
ding dong on the on the on the
tongue clock or whatever yes and each
person flips a coin themselves to decide
am i going to hunt for somebody to
give my number to and let them represent
me
or am i going to sit here and wait for
someone to come
okay uh okay well they they flipped
their coin
some of the people start asking other
people saying hey i would like
you to be my representative here is my
number
but the problem is that there's limited
bandwidth of the people who are getting
asked it's like you can't
get you can't go out to prom with five
people but this is not what we're doing
we're adding numbers okay
but you can only add one number yeah so
the person who has suddenly gotten asked
by all these people
well they'll have to decide who they're
going to take it from
and they randomly just choose one when
they randomly choose one all the others
are rejected and they
don't get to delegate anything in that
round but now if
this person has absorbed this one who
said okay here you take charge of my
number
this person now updates their pointer
you're you're in charge
and this person adds the two numbers
that was the first round
in the next round when they do the coin
flipping this person doesn't flip
anymore because they're just delegating
it's that anyone who has the pointers
themselves that's a
like a person who is in charge of some
number of informations
they flip the coin to decide should i
find other people who are
agents or should i wait for people to
ask me
yes brilliant this is somebody else's
idea and and now the idea is okay if you
just keep doing this process what ends
up happening
oh yeah oh and also by the way if you
decide that you want to go reach out to
other people here's the here's the
here's the here's the catch
when you're one of these agents saying
okay i'm going to go look for someone
you have no idea who in this crowd is an
agent
or somebody who delegated it to someone
else you just pick a random person
when you pick the random person if it
lands on someone and the person says oh
i i actually delegated it to someone
then you
you you follow the club you walk out the
delegation chair lock up delegation
chain and you can do
like path compression in the algorithm
to make it so you don't consistently do
lots of walking up
but the bottom line is that what ends up
happening is that
you end up reaching out whenever you're
one of the ones reaching out
you can think of it as each agent is
responsible for some number of people
it's almost like they're the leader of a
bunch as the process is evolving
you have these lumps each lump has an
agent and when the agent reaches out
they reach out to another
lump where the probability of them
hitting that lump
is proportional to the size of the lump
yeah that is the one funny thing about
this
process this is not that they can reach
out to a uniformly random lump
where every lump has the same chance of
reaching out to yeah
the bigger the lump is the less like
the more likely it is that you end up
reaching that lap
which is a problem let me explain why
that's a problem because
you see you're hoping that this has a
small number of steps yeah but here's a
bad situation that could happen
imagine if you had like there are n
people that you're adding up
imagine that you have exactly square
root of n
lumps left of which
almost all of them are just one person
who is still their own
boss their own their own manager except
one giant one giant one
yeah now what's going to happen is going
to be a huge bottleneck because every
round the giant one can only absorb one
of the others
yes and now you suddenly have time which
is about square root of n
the square root of n is chosen because
that is one where the
the lumps are such that um you really
are limited by this large one
slowly sucking up the rest of them so
the the heart of the question became
well but is that just so unusual that we
don't that it doesn't usually happen
because remember you start with everyone
just being independent it's like a lot
of lumps of size well how naturally do
the big lumps emerge
yes and so what that part of the proof
was was showing that that was a joint
work with al lubetsky
that one was showing that uh actually
in that thing the lumps do kind of get
out of whack and so it's not
the purely logarithmic number of steps
but if you make one very slight change
which is if you are one of the agents
and you have just been propositioned
possibly relayed along
by a couple of different people if you
just say don't take a random one
but accept the smallest lump
that actually does enough to even
distribute the lump size
yeah that's i mean yeah it's fascinating
how would the distributed algorithms a
little
yes make all the difference in the world
yeah
actually by the way this does this back
to our voting conversation this makes me
think of like
these networking systems are so
fascinating to study they they
immediately spring to mind ideas
of how to have representation like i
maybe as opposed to me voting for a
president
i want to vote for for like uh
for you paul to represent me maybe on a
particular issue
and then you'll delegate that further
and then we naturally construct those
kinds of networks
because that that feels like i can have
a good conversation with you and figure
out that you know what you're doing and
i could delegate it to you and
in that way construct a representative
government
or representative decision maker that
feels
that feels really nice as opposed to
like us
like a tree of height one or something
where it's like everybody's just
um it feels like there's a lot of room
for layers of representation to form
organically from the bottom up
i wonder if there are systems like that
this is the cool thing about the
internet
and the digital space where we're so
well connected just like with
the novid app to to distribute
information about the
the the the spread of the disease we can
the same way
in a distributed sense form anything
like
uh any kind of knowledge bases that are
formed in a decentralized way and uh
in a hierarchical way as opposed to sort
of
old way where there's no mechanism for
large scale
fast uh like distributed transactional
information
this is really interesting this is where
almost like network graph theory
becomes practical yeah most of that
exciting work was done in the 20th
century but most of the application will
be in the 21st which is cool to think
about
you